-It's time for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."
Here we go, everyone.
-♪ Good name ♪
♪ Bad name
great name ♪
-First off, we have "Nope."
Well, that is a good name
for a horror movie.
That is a bad name
for a dating app.
It's a great name for what
McDonald's employees say
every time you ask if the
McFlurry machine is working.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nope.
Next, we have "Break my soul."
That's a good name
for a Beyoncé song.
It's a bad name for a show
store.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for
being on hold
with Spectrum cable
customer service.
[ Applause ]
Argh! Forget it!
After that there's
"the gray man."
That's a good name
for a Netflix movie.
It's a bad name for a superhero.
A great name for a retired
member of the Blue Man Group.
[ Laughter, applause ]
He used to be --
Next up, there's
"rolling loud."
Well, that's a good name for a
music festival.
It's a bad name for a nursing
home shuttle.
[ Laughter ]
And a great name for getting
the grocery cart
with the squeaky wheel.
It's like, ah, ah. Sorry
everybody, it's gonna be loud.
[ Applause ]
And finally, there's
"about damn time."
That's a good name
for a Lizzo song.
It's a bad name
for a food delivery app.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for
a documentary about clocks
voiced by Samuel L. Jackson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is all for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."
We have a great show tonight.